gomez exten hat sich neulich erst mal
einen weiteren porsche für seine
sammlung gekauft wie viele andere reiche
briten hatte auch der 37-jährige
influenza während der pandemie kaum
gelegenheit geld auszugeben er ist noch
vermögender geworden ist gab es mehr
möglichkeiten geld zu verdienen als in
diesen zeiten ich sage nicht dass es
einfach ist erfolg zu haben aber wenn
man sich richtig positioniert und die
richtigen leute trifft hat man wirklich
gute chancen
wenn die geschäfte laufen geht tom
shoppen
ich neige dazu ich mich mit so was zu
belohnen ich bin einfach gestrickt
nach zwei jahren ist tom heute zum
ersten mal wieder auf einer
veranstaltung für leute wie ihn leute
mit teuren hobbys tim burton hat in dem
privat tobago in westminster eingeladen
tim ist ein lifestyle manager das ist
jemand der anderen die freizeit
gestaltet möglichst aufregend möglichst
exklusiv und natürlich gegen geld
wir organisieren sachen an die sonst
niemand ran kommt wirklich exklusives
wenn man da einfach anruft hat man keine
chance man muss die richtigen kontakte
und das richtige netzwerk haben
tims kunden wollen dass er ihnen die
türen zu partys und vernissage eröffnet
sie wollen promis treffen und zu abenden
wie diesem eingeladen werden bei denen
sie besprechen wie sie sich gegenseitig
noch reicher machen können
teams job bringt es mit sich dass er
auch auf events wie diesem nicht nur zum
vergnügen auftaucht die luxusmesse elite
führt schon im neunten jahr schöne dinge
und ihre zukünftigen besitzer zusammen
attraktion sind hier die helikopter
man kann überall damit hin er ist nicht
kompliziert zu bedienen man kann alle
kurzstrecken damit erledigen für die
helios sind wir hier
von energiekrise inflation der sich
anbahnenden rezession keine spur das
business boomt die meisten sind der
ansicht dass es nach den fehlenden
vergnügungen während der pandemie alles
nur besser werden kann gewehre autos und
uhren es ist für jeden was dabei
schwärmen auch fraser und linda
[Musik]
es ist hier ein bisschen wie zu den
glücklichen zeiten heute geht es uns
großartig wir sind froh dass es endlich
einen schritt vorwärts geht zurück in
einer art von normalem leben normales
leben ganz einfach
im gemeinschaftszentrum von burnley in
nordengland sieht normales leben anders
aus einmal die woche treffen sich junge
mütter hier weil das kochen und das
leben einfacher sind wenn man sich
unterstützt jenny horn war hat fünf
kinder und einen mann der zum arbeiten
sein auto und also benzin braucht alles
wird teurer nicht nur gas und strom
nicht nur das essen alles wird teurer
man weiß nicht mehr wie man umschichten
soll
während gerade familien im armen norden
nicht wissen wie sie ihre rechnungen
zahlen sollen bereitet sich das land auf
das 70 thronjubiläum der queen vor ein
grund zur freude auch in burnley
ehrlich das ist mir wirklich egal
sie wird wohl bald das zeitliche segnen
sie soll jetzt mal langsam abtreten
[Musik]
sie hat doch keinen einfluss mehr wenn
man den kindern von der queen erzählen
würde würden die sagen wer ist die queen
die habe ich noch nie gesehen das beste
am jubiläum ist die party
doch danach droht wieder der alltag und
der ist härter denn je nach einem
jahrzehnt der sparpolitik der exit und
der pandemie erreichen die
sozialleistungen für bedürftige hinten
und vorne nicht
james anderson ärgert dass und es treibt
ihn an der 54-jährige klempner hat vor
einigen jahren sein unternehmen in eine
non profit organisation verwandelt weil
er auf immer mehr leute traf die es sich
nicht leisten konnten ihre boiler
reparieren zu lassen
die grundidee hinter unserer
organisation ist dass wir die leute da
unterstützen wo sie keine andere hilfe
bekommen da wo lokale behörden oder die
regierung versagen das rettet leben und
reduziert armut
zu kennen bekommt ihre wohnung nicht
warum die 60-jährige hat jahrzehnte als
pflegerin im staatlichen
gesundheitssystem gearbeitet dann
erkrankte sie selbst schwer an der
wirbelsäule und verlor ihren job
ich kann unmöglich den ganzen tag die
heizung an machen ob mir kalt ist oder
nicht ich ziehe meinen mantel an den
ganzen tag
ihre erwerbsunfähigkeit musste vor
gericht beweisen nun bekommt sie 95 euro
pro woche den rest nimmt sie aus ihren
ersparnissen für die rente dafür habe
ich mein ganzes leben gearbeitet
vielen dank großbritannien du bist ein
tolles land wünsche
james findet schnell eine lösung
material arbeit und umsatzsteuer
alles zusammen 231 und 60er es schwierig
für sie das zu zahlen
ja okay dann geben wir ihnen einen
rabatt von 230 und 60 dann zahlen sie
nur ein pfund
ich kann gar nicht sagen wie kalt mir
ist
wenig umsatz große dankbarkeit von
diesen tagen gibt es immer mehr im leben
des james anderson wo besteht wie es
scheint diese trennung zu geben bei der
die leute aus den oberen schichten
denken es sei ihr gottgegebenes recht zu
bekommen was sie haben und es zu
behalten und sie denken dass es unser
job als unterschicht ist auf dem boden
zu sitzen und darauf zu warten bis die
brotkrumen vom tisch fallen
sie leben immer noch in predigt
organischen zeiten so wie sie denken und
das land regieren
die nachfahrin victorias feiert in
diesen tagen ihr 70 stone jubiläum das
land seiner alten traditionen
zuneigung zu der alten dame vermischt
sich mit nostalgie und nationalstolz
doch selten war die not größer in ihrem
armen königreich